if you are not using AI tools every day
of your life you're making a huge
mistake you've got to start training
whether you need it or not is irrelevant
you're gonna need it this train has left
the station and there's nothing stopping
it
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
are you afraid of dying at all but I
will say that I got a lot better I mean
I used to really be scared of it I
definitely hit the next level of like oh
I'm grateful that I got this much and
including my parents and including other
people I love especially with parents
that lost a parent you know my dad lost
his dad at 15. my mom lost her mom at
five six
devastating so that was like a cloud in
my life why am I driven by gratitude
that's a heavy cloud in your life and as
a kid it hung on me and so yes I I do
fear it and I fear it right now I
wouldn't want to go now too much to do
yeah too many of you to flip get your
perspective right before I get the [__]
out of here what is a practical way for
a leader to not use fear but still
motivate their team
hope to use love other side of the coin
optimism I think Candor in truth like
there's ways to make a lot of things
good there is no perfect I think so many
people crippled by Perfect there's no
perfect state but there's better than
the alternative for all the managers
upper middle management even c-suite but
it isn't the CEO whoever you are older
brother and sister with parents if
you're in a framework where you're not
the final final decision maker if you
talk to the person you're trying to
motivate there's a way to Corral
multiple energies there but the way you
do that is by telling them I know I feel
so blue I need a meal like you uh I need
some just some friends and some jury I'm
trying to get like you uh
Flex On The Ground like you show all my
bands like you I talk to my friends I
talk to my family they don't understand
like you follow the plan like you I need
some fans like you make em all stand
like you but I don't understand why I'm
not like you taking care
we're very interested being an authentic
Duty expert what we're trying to explore
why we brought Vayner in was because we
wanted to find a way to do it that was
coming from a place of authentic
collaboration we want to work with
beauty experts who make content and find
a way to elevate creators that are
passionate about the subject have great
followings without telling them what to
do how to say it I think the store as a
production facility is a big deal if I
get a DM that says you're one of the
people that's allowed to come and we're
doing three hours where our store is the
production facility and all the product
and all the real estate of the retail
store is yours I think the content and
the creative what you're trying to
accomplish in that environment is
profound it's intriguing enough for them
to say yes which will then solve
everything that we're trying to figure
out after that and I think it would work
really well
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hi everybody thank you for coming I've
been making music for about five years
now what advice do you have for artists
like myself that are trying to push the
personal brand on as many platforms as
we possibly can without feeling like we
are forcing it because I do find myself
a little overwhelmed with what I have to
keep up with if he feels overwhelming or
guilty like you don't have to the
reality of all of this is if you can't
do something that genuinely makes you
happy it's not going to work out anyway
if you're doing it because you're trying
to build a career but it's not enjoyable
that is not a sustainable model
ironically my piece of advice is to
maybe take a break like I built my
career in 2006 on YouTube making wine
videos and then I didn't want to and
everyone said I was crazy when I stopped
making wine videos and started making
business videos Everybody in the wine
business told me that I was making the
biggest mistake of my career so what do
I think I think you have to make this
work for your soul
foreign
[Music]
my favorite nft actually was the
Southern Scholarship yeah I I got
through the first round nice I was like
I'm really happy about that I didn't
after that so then I was like oh I want
to try to you know flip up to something
then when I finally got it I understood
what you were saying about is the
process of trying yes yeah it wasn't as
fulfilling it was the stuff before that
was fulfilling it's such a revelation
for me now what gets exciting is once
you understand that it makes life so
much more enjoyable once you realize
it's genuinely the journey that nothing
you put on a pedestal is actually as
good as trying to get to it it makes
everything fun
foreign
a lot of familiar faces a lot of new
faces I hope the wine and the food is
good I think the other thing that
everyone's going to be blown away by is
how quickly you're going to use AI in
your everyday life sure some of you saw
some of the plugins that chatgpt is
doing with like food ordering Services
can you imagine being able to say to a
device like an Alexa seven of my friends
are coming over two of them are lactose
intolerance three are vegan one loves
Tomatoes three prefer onions can you
place an order on seamless and ship it
to us right away and also email me the
ingredients of every product and you're
done and that happens that is profound
if you are not using AI tools every day
of your life you're making a huge
mistake you've got to start training
whether you need it or not is irrelevant
you're gonna need it this train has left
the station and there's nothing stopping
it
oh I'm an actor and I'm a content
creator how do I you know split into
other things but also at the same time
with my cool content how do I monetize
it brand deals are very real I think the
question becomes are you business
developing enough to get the deals
meaning if I'm you I'm probably dming 50
people a day just saying hey I look what
you're doing or hey I'm a fan putting
yourself on the radar because the second
they look over at your account they're
going to realize oh there's potential to
do something here what I would call the
Soft Cell but you need to be the
aggressor to see what will come back to
you when you reach out to these brands
[Music]
see you tomorrow
just earlier this week some 1000 notable
signatories came out with an open letter
asking AI labs to pause for six months
and so where do you stand on that do we
need to slow down I don't think we can
slow down
you know dailyvee
um this trip has been really productive
you know it's fun to expand globally
right I want people to stay here for as
long as possible and if we create a
great culture then they will and so you
know I appreciate that I'm happy for you
foreign
[Music]